on habitait dans une maison squattée de
ma naissance à un mais six ans au milieu
des cafards des enseignes tout déraille
et les violences commencent les
violences physiques la violence verbale
qu'est ce qui s'est passé qui avez quoi
comme violence 1 il y avait des coups de
poing des coups de pied des coups de
bâton j'ai vu j'ai vu mon petit frère de
16 ans fait rejeter un casque de scooter
de plein fouet par par mon père
donc tu faire tomber par terre sa
respiration coupée devant les yeux de ma
mère j'ai vu des coups de balai des coup
de raclette et j'ai reçu aussi s'écoule
à un des coups de chaussures de sécurité
en fait tout ce qu'ils pouvaient prendre
comme projectiles pour bien nous faire
mal il le faisait après il ya aussi un
de mes oncles j'ai vu taper devant
devant les yeux les unes mes parents un
lui lui mettre des coups de tête à
plusieurs reprises parce que tout
simplement il est homosexuel il ya donc
fois